[Musique]
prendre le temps de contempler ses
oeuvres de jeter un regard nouveau
pour la première fois le musée lambinet
investi l'espace richaud à versailles
une cinquantaine de pièces ont été
choisies pour leur caractère original
précieux historique
les collections exposées ici sont
justement le reflet de l'histoire du
musée qui hérite donc d'une riche
tradition de donateurs et on se présente
en effet au musée lambinet comme un
musée de collectionneurs et vous avez
ici les grands donateurs qui ont fait
l'histoire de notre patrimoine municipal
à découvrir ou redécouvrir ce portrait
de charlotte corday célèbre pour avoir
assassiné mara pendant la révolution
française ou encore cette horloge du
xviiie siècle
pièce maîtresse de cette collection cet
art réalisée par le luthier de
marie-antoinette témoignage de l'art de
vivre à versailles ou xviiie siècle elle
se trouvait dans l'appartement
reconstitué au musée lambinet j'ai en
effet choisi en dehors de la fiche de
mètres cette oeuvre
au centre de cette même chapelle pour
lui donner vraiment une vraie majesté
voyez elle n'a même pas besoin de socles
en fait elle est posée à même le sol
mais le sol lui même donne 1
un vrai élan en fait à 7 à cette pièce
qui est particulièrement précieuse
les pièces visibles jusqu'au 17 novembre
à l'espace richard rejoindront ensuite
leur place habituelle au musée lambinet
soit en réserve soit dans le parcours
permanent
[Musique]